si vous pensez que par un coup de
sifflet à l'Assemblée nationale vous
allez faire en sorte que les Français
que les Français retournent retournent
chez eux et boss comme des brutes du
jour au lendemain vous vous trompez
absolument si c'est ce que vous tombez
républicanisme permanente gardez-les
pour vous parce que je fais partie je
fais aussi aucune mais à l'instant
écoutez vous-même arrêtez avec de ce
qu'est la réalité
je ne vous ai pas coupé une seule fois
mais là on débarque c'est intéressant
d'ailleurs je lui souhaite juste être
assis dans les rues
ok arrêtez vous accusations permanentes
et vous savez plus je vous vois plus je
comprends pourquoi les Français ne
peuvent plus vous blairer franchement
Miss parce que
vous n'êtes pas respecté les gens quand
vous avez votre quand vous avez activez
vos opposants vous êtes irrespectueuse
non si je peux juste terminer une phrase
pas du tout je suis très tranquille et
très serein je fais partie d'une
génération
oui j'ai très peur pour les Français
d'une génération qui a grandi en se
mobilisant contre le contrat première le
contrat aussi vous n'avez jamais bossé
monsieur vous n'avez jamais bossé j'ai
été enseigné
enseignant plusieurs années vous vous
avez bossé ou dans une chaîne où il y a
toute une
série vous
avez fini sur la réforme
j'étais enseignant et croyez-moi quand
on est en ce moment-là vous êtes un
appareil
insulter les enseignants non en parlant
de cette manière là vous insultez les
enseignants j'ai travaillé plusieurs
années comme enseignant à Sarcelles et
quand on enseigne à Sarcelles on connaît
le monde du travail j'ai enseigné 8 ans
avant d'être élu parce que moi j'ai été
élu vous n'avez pas été une seule fois
parler de la réforme des retraites et
pas d'attaques personnelles
le Contrat Première Embauche il a été
adopté et c'est après qu'il ait été
adopté que finalement il n'a pas été
appliqué parce que le mouvement social
c'est poursuivi ça n'était pas une
atteinte à la République on a tout à
fait le droit d'avoir des mobilisations
y compris quand un texte est adopté et
ça ne pose aucun espèce de problème
démocratique donc oui je le dis la
mobilisation se poursuivra y compris
s'il y a un vote favorable parce qu'on
ne gouverne pas durablement un pays
quand une réforme est à ce point rejetée
et ça vaudra pour la réforme des
retraites et vous en apercevrez
[Musique]